[Musique]
tous les autres spécimens de
gorgosaure qui ont été trouvés sont dans
les musées, c'est le seul
que vous pouvez réellement acheter, donc c'est
vraiment un moment excitant
et même si le t-rex est plus
connu
dans le genre, vous savez.  esprits populaires euh
gorgosaurus, je pense que c'était un
prédateur au sommet plus efficace, sa taille légèrement plus petite et
sa vitesse, donc si vous regardez, il a une
très longue queue
et des pattes très puissantes,
euh parce que c'était un chasseur, si vous regardez
les dents,
ce sont eux.  C'est comme un
couteau à steak à double tranchant avec des dentelures de chaque côté, donc
il a été utilisé pour déchirer et déchirer les
corps.
[Musique] Les
ventes récentes de squelettes montés
comme celui-ci ont extrêmement bien marché aux enchères en raison de
la rareté de cela et du
fait que
il est très peu probable que nous en
trouvions un autre prochainement à vendre. Je
prévois que cela fonctionnerait très
bien pour
vous. [Musique]